TOOK SOME TIME FOR IT TO COME
TOGETHER AND FOR THOSE
ARRANGEMENTS TO BE MADE.
SO THIS IS CERTAINLY GOOD NEWS
FOR THOSE SEVEN FAMILIES.
THE PRESIDENT SAYING TODAY WE
CELEBRATE THAT SEVEN FAMILIES
WILL BE WHOLE ONCE MORE.
>> YES, THOSE FAMILIES MUST BE
VERY HAPPY.
ARLETTE SAENZ, THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
>>> CLOSE ALLY OF RUSSIAN
PRESIDENT VLADIMIR PUTIN SAYS IT
IS TIME TO USE NUCLEAR WEAPONS
IN UKRAINE.
THAT IS FROM THE LEADER OF THE
CHECHEN REPUBLIC WHO PUT OUT AN
ANGRY STATEMENT SLAMMING RUSSIAN
GENERALS AFTER REPORTS THAT
RUSSIAN TROOPS ARE RETREATING
FROM PARTS OF UKRAINE.
THAT LEADER URGING PUTIN TO TAKE
DRASTIC MEASURES INCLUDING THE
USE OF LOW YIELD NUCLEAR
WEAPONS.
FAREED ZAKARI TALKED ABOUT IT
WITH THE U.S. DEFENSE SECRETARY
LLOYD AUSTIN.
>> PART OF THE ANNEXATION,
RUSSIA'S ANNEXATION, IS THE
STATEMENT BY PRESIDENT PUTIN
THAT HE HAS NOW MADE TWICE THAT
THESE TERRITORIES ARE NOW
RUSSIAN AND THAT HE WILL DEFEND
THESE RUSSIAN TERRITORIES WITH
EVERY MEANS POSSIBLE.
AND RUSSIAN MEDIA HAS REPEATEDLY
INTERPRETED THAT TO MEAN VERY
SPECIFICALLY NUCLEAR WEAPONS AS
HAS DMITRY MEDVEDEV.
SO THIS SEEMS TO RAISE THE
STAKES ENORMOUSLY.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THE FACT
THAT VLADIMIR PUTIN IS
ESSENTIALLY SAYING AT THIS POINT
THAT IF HE FEELS THAT THERE IS
AN ATTACK FROM NATO, I SUPPOSE,
ON RUSSIAN TERRITORY WHICH ALSO
INCLUDES ALL OF THE DONBAS, HE
RESERVES THE RIGHT TO USE
NUCLEAR WEAPONS IN RESPONSE?
>> AGAIN, IT IS AN ILLEGAL
CLAIM, IT IS AN IRRESPONSIBLE
STATEMENT.
THESE ARE -- NUCLEAR SABER
RATTLING IS NOT WHAT WE WOULD
EXPECT TO HEAR FROM LEADERS OF
LARGE COUNTRIES WITH CAPABILITY.
AND SO WHAT WE CAN EXPECT TO
SEE, WE CAN EXPECT THAT THE
UKRAINIANS WILL CONTINUE TO MOVE
FORWARD AND ATTEMPT TO TAKE BACK
ALL OF THE TERRITORY WITHIN
THEIR SOVEREIGN BORDERS HERE.
AND SO I DON'T THINK THAT THAT
IS GOING TO STOP.
AND WE WILL CONTINUE TO SUPPORT
THEM IN THEIR EFFORTS.
>> AND YOU CAN SEE MORE OF THAT
INTERVIEW ON FAREED ZAKARI GPS
TOMORROW AT 10:00 A.M.
BUT RIGHT NOW, WE WANT TO BRING
IN RETIRED BRIGADIER GENERAL AND
AUTHOR OF "SWIMMING THE VOLGA."
GENERAL, SO GREAT TO SEE YOU.
THANKS FOR BEING HERE.
YOU HEARD THE DEFENSE SECRETARY
THERE, HE AND MANY OTHER U.S.
OFFICIALS STILL THINK IT IS
UNLIKELY PUTIN WILL RESORT TO
NUCLEAR WEAPONS.
I CAN'T EVEN BELIEVE WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT THIS.
BUT WHAT DOES IT MEAN THAT ONE
OF HIS KEY ALLIES IS NOW URGING
HIM DO IT, IS HE JUST PLAYING TO
DOMESTIC POLITICAL BASE MUCH
LIKE WE MIGHT SEE FROM TIME TO
TIME HERE IN THIS COUNTRY?
>> JIM, I THINK THAT IT IS ALL
OF IT.
I THINK THAT THERE IS
INTIMIDATION TRYING TO
INTIMIDATE THE U.S., TRYING TO
INTIMIDATE THE ALLIES, TRYING TO
INTIMIDATE THE UKRAINIANS.
BUT IT CAN'T PLAY.
THE FACT THAT THE CHECHNYA,
PUTIN STRONG MAN, MADE THAT
STATEMENT IS INFORMATIVE, BUT
THEY ARE ABSOLUTELY -- THEIR
PEOPLE HAVE BEEN IN UKRAINE AND
PERFORMED UGLY.
AND THEN ALSO DMITRY MEDVEDEV
WHO USED TO BE THE PRESIDENT AND
ONCE WAS BEHIND IN PART THE
RUSSIAN RESET HAS GONE
COMPLETELY THE OTHER WAY.
I BELIEVE IT IS RHETORIC, BUT AS
THE DEFENSE SECRETARY SAID AND
THE ADMINISTRATION, THIS IS
DEADLY SERIOUS STUFF, IT IS
RHETORIC AND THIS SHOULD GO BACK
CHANNEL.
I KNOW IT IS.
WE NEED TO STAY FOCUSED.
WE DON'T RECOGNIZE THE ILLEGAL
ANNEXATION OF THESE FOUR
REPUBLICS -- PROVINCES AND WE'LL
CONTINUE TO SUPPORT THE
UKRAINIANS IN THEIR FIGHT FOR
SURVIVAL.
>> AND FOR OUR VIEWERS AT HOME
WHO MAY NOT UNDERSTAND THE
TERMINOLOGY, WHAT IS A LOW YIELD
NUCLEAR WEAPON?
>> HOE YIELD, I MEAN, THAT CAN
BE AS LOW AS ONE KILITON, WHICH
IS 1,000 POUNDS OF TNT.
AND IT COULD BE AS LOW AS THAT.
HIROSHIMA AND NAKASAKI BETWEEN
SOMEWHERE BETWEEN 10 AND 15.
BUT WHATEVER IT IS, IT IS LETHAL
WHETHER IT IS MULTIPLE BLOCKS, A
TOWN, A SMALL CITY, BUT IT IS
THERE.
AND IT IS VERY DANGEROUS.
>> WE'VE BEEN TALKING ABOUT
RUSSIANS RETREATING FROM
DONETSK.
IS THIS WHAT PUTIN WANTS TO TRY
TO CLAIM THAT UKRAINE IS
ATTACKING RUSSIAN TERRITORY?
>> I THINK THAT THE PRESS, THE
PUSH THAT UKRAINIANS ARE MAKING
ARE TOTALLY JUSTIFIED INTO THEIR
LANDS OF DONETSK, OF LUHANSK,
ZAPORIZHZHIA AND KHERSON.
AND SO THEIR PEOPLE EVACUATING,
THEY ARE EVACUATING FOR THE
FIGHT THAT THEY DIDN'T ALL VOTE
85%, 90% FOR THE REFERENDUM AND
THAT IS INDEED A SHAM.
I THINK THAT WE SHOULD PAY
ATTENTION TO THE OVERESTIMATED
200,000 ABLE BODIED MOSTLY MALES
WHO HAVE LEFT RUSSIA THROUGH
FINLAND AND THROUGH GEORGIA AND
OTHER MEANS.
THAT IS A FACT.
AND WHILE WE'RE WORRIED WITH THE
PROLONGED WAR AND THE 300,000
THAT ARE BEING CALLED UP, IT MAY
ALSO ACCELERATE TROUBLE FOR THE
PUTIN REGIME INTERNALLY BECAUSE
WHAT THEY HAVE DONE IS
SOCIALIZED AND ENERIZED THE
POPULATION.
THIS IS AN UGLY WAR AND PEOPLE
LEAVING ARE A REAL INDICATOR.
THEY ARE VOTING WITH THEIR FEET.
>> AND THESE DEVELOPMENTS, THIS
ANNEXATION, THE SHAM ANNEXATION
FROM VLADIMIR PUTIN, IT IS
STEPPING UP CALLS FROM UKRAINIAN
OFFICIALS TO JOIN NATO, THEY
WANT TO JOIN NATO.
YOUR THOUGHTS ON THAT.
>> MY THOUGHTS ARE THAT MY
HEART, JIM, IS YES, IN MANY WAYS
UKRAINIANS HAVE EARNED IT
MILITARILY.
BUT MY MIND SAYS NOT NOW.
DO EVERYTHING THAT WE CAN DO TO
IT IN-TO SUPPORT AND EVEN MORE
AND BETTER WEAPONS, TO HELP
UKRAINIANS TAKE THEIR LAND BACK.
NATO WILL PLAY INTO THE
RUSSIAN
EXISTENTIAL NARRATIVE AT HOME
AND ALSO IT MAY CREATE
DIVISIONS, JIM, IN THE ALLIANCE
BECAUSE THERE IS NO GUARANTEE
ALL 30 NATIONS WILL VOTE FOR
UKRAINE IN NATO.
SO I THINK THE DOOR IS OPEN, BUT
WE SUPPORT UKRAINIANS TO PUSH ON
EVERY FRONT.
AND THEN ISOLATE THE RUSSIANS.
ABSOLUTELY FEROCIOUSLY,
DIPLOMATICALLY, ECONOMICALLY AND
ALL THE OTHER TOOLS THAT WE
HAVE.
BUT NATO IN THE FUTURE WOULD --
THEY ARE WORKING BUT NOW IS NOT
THE TIME.
>> AND PRESIDENT BIDEN HAS
CALLED THE LEAK IN THE NORD
STREAM PIPELINES A DELIBERATE
ACT OF SABOTAGE.
HE STOPPED SHORT OF BLAMING THE
KREMLIN FOR THE LEAK.
WHAT DO YOU THINK ABOUT THAT?
>> I DON'T KNOW, BUT EVERYTHING
THAT I'M READING AND SENSING IS
THAT VERY LIKELY RUSSIAN,
WHETHER NAVY OR OTHER MARITIME
OR SOME, WENT IN -- IT IS ONE
THING IF YOU SLASHED A HOLE
OR -- IN ONE.
BUT WHEN YOU START SAYING THREE
OR FOUR AND THE NORDIC NATIONS
ARE REPORTING THAT RUSSIAN FLEET
IS IN THE AREA, IT IS -- YOU
KNOW, IT ISCLOSEST THING TO A
SMOKING GUN WITHOUT DIRECT
PROOF.
SO FOR NOW I THINK THAT WE HAVE
TO LOOK AT IT, BUT IT ALSO SHOWS
JUST THE MALIGN ASPECT OF THIS
REGIME THAT WILL DO ANYTHING, IF
YOU WILL, TO GET AN EDGE AND TRY